(laughs)
- Hey, guys.
Right at the outset I have to tell you
Bear is okay.
He's doing well.
Come on, little puppy.
Good boy.
(laughs) Look at his giant face.
Clean your face,
you're on camera.
He isn't going traveling.
This isn't his neck pillow.
This is his anti-lick-his-incision pillow.
Basically, he can't turn
around all the way with this
'cause it's so big.
And if he wants to lick
himself he just can't.
He's been wearing this for the last week.
He's pretty comfy with
it and used to it by now.
But what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna take it off for the video
'cause I can watch him right now
and make sure he doesn't lick anything
that he's not supposed to except me.
The surgery that he had was,
you may have guessed it.
He was neutered.
Snip snip for poor little Bear.
There is a few reasons why I
decided to get Bear neutered,
but that wasn't an easy decision.
I actually went back
and forth a few times.
First of all,
Bear has a snaggle tooth.
I don't know if anyone has seen it.
He has this snaggle tooth
and I was kind of worried
if it would bother him long-term.
So I thought
let's do two birds with
one stone type situation.
Get him neutered,
and while he's under anesthesia
they can A, clean his teeth,
and B, get the tooth out.
However,
when this little guy
went under anesthesia,
they did x-rays
and they found that he
has an extra canine tooth.
Bear, you have three canines.
If you're wondering,
the canine tooth is this
bottom tooth right here.
The big one.
And he literally has an extra
one that's growing outward.
When the doctor did the x-rays,
it seemed like the roots
were so interconnected
with all the other teeth,
that by taking it out
there may be damage
done to the other teeth.
She was worried about that.
So she explained that
since he's eating well,
there's no pain,
there's no discomfort,
they decided to keep the tooth in.
So Bear is still having his three canines.
The pros to neutering
a dog really come from
A, it changes their behavior
for the better slightly
for male dominant dogs,
there's decreased marking,
decreased humping,
decreased reaction to females in heat.
Bear didn't have any
of those really issues.
I mean occasionally, when
he would see a female dog,
he would get really excited.
He's not aggressive in anyway.
He's super friendly.
Then I started looking and doing research
on what would be the pros from
a health standpoint for Bear.
I have to say at the outset
of this I'm not a vet.
I am a medical doctor,
although some people have gotten
that confused in the past.
Roxy.
(woman speaking Italian)
The things that I found were
mainly from quality research.
And speaking with some really
experienced dog trainers,
veterinarians, things like that.
So if you're thinking
about neutering your dog,
don't neuter your dog simple because
your dog is doing something
that you don't like
and you think that's gonna be a cure-all.
Train your dog.
I think for controlling the
pet population in general
it's a good idea,
but you shouldn't be
using it as a cure-all
for some behavioral issue
unless it's specifically
recommended to you
by a veterinarian
and/or a trained behavioral
specialist for dogs.
Now Bear never really had any issues.
He was attacked one time
and that's a crazy video.
I'll link that down below.
But in general he's a happy Newf,
he loves playing with other dogs.
Lately, I haven't been
letting him play with dogs
because I'm trying to get him
ready for his certification
to come with me to the hospital.
And we want Bear to be
well-trained for that.
So I haven't been letting him play
with too many puppies in the dog park.
Mostly just Roxy when she comes to visit
or he goes to visit her.
There's a lot more health
benefits for spaying a female dog
than neutering a male dog.
There are decreases in
some cancers for male dogs
like testicular, prostate issues.
But in reality,
not too many health benefits.
There are certain studies going around
saying that dogs who are
neutered live longer.
I take those studies with a grain of salt
because dogs that have been neutered
generally get better veterinary care,
they have owners that
are attentive to them.
It's no surprise that they live longer.
At least there is evidence
that they don't live a shorter live
because some people have said that.
"Oh my god, your gonna
take away the testosterone.
"That means dogs are gonna
live a shorter life."
That's not true.
We have evidence of that at least.
My main reason why I wanted to neuter Bear
is if I travel and I'm
gone for a day or two,
and I leave Bear with my dad or a friend,
I don't want the possibility
or Bear becoming a baby daddy.
- [Maury] You are the father!
- And I don't want to
pay doggy child support
when he impregnates a little chihuahua.
- Hey, hey, hey.
- So we got Bear fixed
primarily for that reason.
He's doing great after the operation.
He's like a happy Newf.
He's healing well.
(Bear hiccups)
Did you get hiccups on camera?
Oh, he has hiccups!
Oh my god, Dad,
you have to show the footage of him
when he was a little baby
having hiccups on my lap.
(Bear hiccups)
He has hiccups.
(Bear hiccuping)
Growing pups always have hiccups.
That's not new.
So that doesn't even concern me.
(Bear hiccups)
(laughs)
If you have any questions
about what it's like to
get your dog neutered,
or you're wondering whether you should,
drop a comment down below.
I'm not a vet but I can share
my own personal experiences
and things that I found online.
Bear, are excited to open up some mail?
(Bear barks)
Good boy.
Wow, he went in my face for that.
Speak.
(Bear barks)
(laughs)
High five.
Whoa, that was close.
You almost hit me right in the face.
This one's from Finley.
Okay.
It's something dense.
"It's a burrito tortilla
blanket for adults and kinds."
(laughs)
Wrap me in this burrito.
It looks so (mumbles).
"So you can be all wrapped up
"for the upcoming winter season.
"Casey."
Aww.
This is a big one from Revive Drinkware.
"Dr. Mike.
"First off, you need to know "
"that because of your first
morning routine video,
"I've started diligently floss everyday."
Well, done.
"Thank you so much
"for the content you're
producing for all of us.
"I honestly cannot fully express
"how incredibly helpful I find
"to have such an immediate
and entertaining resource
"for varying healthcare topics."
Well, thank you for that, Madeleine.
And let's see what we got here.
First we got a stainless steel mug!
Aww.
Stay happy and healthy.
Look at that.
And ready?
Bam!
This is fire.
Let's see what the other one is.
She got two.
In case I need to go for a walk/run.
Dude!
This is way too good.
Even the font you chose
is better than (giggles).
Madeleine, you're good.
Okay, we got a shirt.
A, D, C, D, E, F, G,
H, I, J, K, L, M, N, O,
oh, P, Q, R, S, T!
- I don't get it.
- Only doctors/nurses/health
professionals will get this.
This is a P wave.
That's a Q wave,
R wave, S wave, T wave.
I want to wear this one day to work
when I'm just coming in to do notes.
And I'm telling you my hospital's
gonna go bonkers for it.
This is hilarious.
Well done.
Yankika Nix from the Netherlands.
"Artwork inside. Careful."
Oh, I feel like a kid on Christmas.
And Christmas is coming up.
"Bear inside!"
At least I'm not cutting
myself with the letter opener
like I did last time.
(yelling)
"Hi, Dr. Mike.
"Hopefully the bear pup has
made it to your doorstep safely.
"I hope you like the drawing.
"I wanted to thank you or your
way of practicing medicine.
"Patient, understanding, and
looking at the bigger picture
"is important for both the
patient and the doctor."
I thank you for saying that.
(gasps)
This is crazy!
Bear, this is you!
Oh my god.
No, don't lick it.
Don't lick it, don't lick it.
(Mike barks)
(laughs)
This is just,
it's next level.
This is gonna be a main
attraction in my home.
This is ridiculous.
Thank you.
Naomi Bishop from Wyoming!
Ooh.
The DO symbol with Doctor Mike on it.
I love that.
Ooh, it's a little canvas.
(laughs) This is too adorable.
Monet Roxy and Bear.
Naomi, you crushed it.
This is from Carol.
Sereni-tea.
Aww.
Sereni-tea, get it?
(toy squeaks)
Bear, catch.
You really has to draw the herpe.
(scratchy violins)
This is really good.
That's really sweet.
"Hey, Mike.
"I am -- and I'm a
great fan of your videos
"and you're amazing mentor.
"I'm premed at UMD.
"If I could receive an autograph,
"it would mean a lot to me
only if you get some time."
Aww, that's awesome, will do.
"Dear Dr. Mike,
"My name is Romani and
I'm 32 from Germany.
"And I'm sending you a
drawing of you and Bear.
"I want to say thank you for
the great YouTube channel.
"It's funny, informative,
"and I really enjoy watching it.
"I'm not healthy 'cause I have cancer,
"but I try and stay happy no matter what.
"Drawing is my daily healthy drug
"that helps keep me happy,
"and of course watching
you and Bear on YouTube.
"So thank you and I hope
you like my drawing."
Wow.
(jazzy music)
It's great.
Last but not least.
(gasps)
It's a bacteria.
No, it's a mitochondria!
Powerhouse.
This is hilarious.
I love giant microbes.
Thank you for the mitochondria.
Check out a playlist of Bear
and Roxy videos right here.
I love playing with these pups
and I know you're gonna enjoy it.
(jazzy music)